all right we have gotten to the point
where the President of the United States
in what is obviously a desperate and
crazed sort of last-ditch effort to try
to make the case that he's not obviously
violating the emoluments Clause of the
Constitution is now calling the
emoluments clause to the Constitution in
and of itself phony that's his word not
mine now as you may know Donald Trump
has endlessly been clearly violating the
emoluments clause I will redefine what
that clause is for you momentarily just
so we're all on the same page the
strategy from Trump ist's has been first
to deny that he's violating the
emoluments clause that has mostly failed
since he's so obviously and brazenly
continuing to violate the emoluments
clause to the Constitution then they
shifted to pretending that the
emoluments clause to the Constitution is
part of the Constitution but not really
like it's sort of this appendage to the
Constitution it's an irrelevant vestige
of sorts it doesn't really matter of
course that's also not true either
we value the Constitution or we don't
either the value of the Constitution is
complete or it is not and you can't pick
and choose when it is and is not worthy
or deserved of being adhered to and now
Donald Trump is straight up saying
including to his supposedly
constitutional conservative followers
that the emoluments clause is phony
Trump spoke to the media yesterday
including about trying to have the g7 at
his personal club Doral a plan which has
since been cancelled by the way because
it also would be an obvious violation of
the emoluments clause to the
Constitution Trump was asked about it
and he said you people with this phony
emoluments clause other presidents if
you look by the process were wealthy not
huge wealth George Washington was
actually considered a very very rich man
at the time but they ran their
businesses George Washington they say
had two desks he had a presidential desk
in a business des
I don't think you people with Estonia
monument laws and by the way I would say
that it's cost me anywhere from two to
five billion dollars to be president and
that's okay between what I lose in what
I could have made you'll notice there
Donald Trump also defending a president
being president and running a business
while being president of the United
States and in so doing casually equating
himself to George Washington it's it's
interesting that there are so many other
crazy things that he says in that 31
second clip that equating himself to
George Washington is not even the
primary thing that we are talking about
like that that's how outrageous the
status quo is it's time for a reality
check
the emoluments clause is the
Constitution its article 1 section 9 and
it says no title of nobility shall be
granted by the United States and no
person holding any office of profit and
trust under them shall without the
consent of Congress except of any
present emolument office or title of any
kind whatever from any King prince or
foreign state
that's the Constitution of the United
States article 1 section 9 it's not the
only relevant emoluments related portion
of the Constitution we also have article
2 section 1 which says the President
shall at stated times receive for his
services a compensation which shall
neither be increased nor diminished
during the period for which he shall
have been elected and he shall not
receive within that period any other
emolument from the United States or any
of them so what do the constitutional
conservatives say about this Trump meant
phony as a metaphor maybe I don't know I
haven't heard any defenses yet because I
think increasingly the constitutional
conservatives are pretending that they
never really wanted Trump to be
President anyway and Oh what me vote for
Trump no I don't remember what I did in
November of 2016 if there is one thing
that won't be able to be said once this
nightmare is over and hopefully that
nightmare is over in 15 months although
it could be 4 years and 15 months
we will not be able to say that people
simply had no idea what Donald Trump was
doing because he's telling us he's
saying that running a business while
being president is fine he's telling us
that he sees inconvenient parts of the
Constitution as phony this is actually
once again impeachable what what I mean
by that is violating the emoluments
clause endlessly that is impeachable and
that's been going on for two and a half
years however long it's been at this
point the publicly calling of the
emoluments clause phony is also in and
of itself impeachable because Donald
Trump swore an oath to uphold the
Constitution and he's publicly saying
that there's a piece of the Constitution
which he swore to uphold on a Bible
remember he's saying well there's a part
of that Constitution that not only am I
not going to uphold in my mind it's
phony that is impeachable publicly
admitting to the dereliction of the oath
that he swore to uphold you can forget
if you want about the first two and a
half years of the donald trump
presidency
merely based on the last seven days
alone Donald Trump is impeachable it's
not clear there are going to be any
consequences and the next thing I want
to talk about won't we listen if we're
going to talk about consequences we have
to talk about legally issued subpoenas
by a co-equal branch of government as
enshrined by the Constitution and the
rule of law which the Trump
administration is ignoring and that's
where we need to go next